[Musik]
als sebastian uns erzählt als das amt
xbox immer menschen gibt es die ihren
hund mit hilfe von programmiererin
knüpfen
das sprechen beigebracht wann wir schon
ein bisschen skeptisch anfang habe ich
tatsächlich wieder vor das ist echt cool
meinen zweiten mal gucken möchten so
warte mal ganz gut
also probieren wir das mit unseren 1
[Musik]
angefangen hat das ganze damals dass die
sprachtherapeutin christina hammer
angeblich erfolgreich eine methode der
unterstützten kommunikation auf ihren
hund stelle angewandt hat denkst du uns
noch mal so gut
ich will sagen davon erstmal an die
buttons auszupacken um sie schauen ob
die kleine made for angst hat oder nicht
wahrscheinlich schon
man muss übrigens dazu sagen dass unsere
hohen kleine angst ist das heißt die hat
nicht nur ganz leicht der vergangenheit
aber wenn sie sich bei uns wohlfühlt
dann verhält sie sich auch wie sowie
ihres quartiers und das ist schon recht
lustig also nicht mal ein bisschen
schräg mal du kannst du auch wenn sie so
viel angst hat ist ihm eigentlich lieber
intelligenter runde
essen man wird dieses geräusch damit
verknüpften dass sie etwas zu essen
trinkt
ich war darauf dass sie dass sie zu mir
kommt wenn das klingt weil dann wissen
wir dass es verknüpft hatte
[Musik]
sie können sprechen einfach geniert
die ist nicht kommen nicht mehr
hinterher alter in gestungshausen würde
interessieren wie lange es gebraucht hat
bis ihr das jetzt geschafft hat 36
minuten und 17 sekunden hat es gedauert
sie mal gelernt hat auf knopfdruck
nachlässen zu verlangen aber bis jetzt
hat also viel machen ihren daumen
nachgeholfen hat es auch gar nicht
das rad hat bei ihr so weiß dass etwas
fehlt man sich drauf drückt und das
liegt nicht mehr richtig frech einfach
gesagt hey oder geh jetzt lecker ich
habe es verdient
die fühlen sich verarscht recht darauf
macht jetzt
[Musik]
was macht sie mal wenn wir weggehen und
den button ignorieren weiß sie schon
dass sie den schlüssel zu unendlich
leckerli vor ihrer nase hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
scheinbar noch nicht aber bald
kann sich noch daran erinnern kopf ja
schon verrückt ich dachte dass die sich
das leichte märkte aber ich glaube ich
muss sie noch mal zeigen wie man muss
nehmen was man kriegt
manchmal habe ich jetzt mal selber drauf
kommt
das ist getrübt super dass ich zu
anstrengend sein kann so wie man sie mal
ein bisschen entspannen mal nämlich ganz
schön angst vor diesen ganzen filme
kuhlmann das herumsteht zweimal gleich
[Musik]
jetzt zu sagen wir bestanden runtergehen
die zuschauer das ist unfassbar
okay was ich jetzt mal probieren werde
ich dass ich einen button war wegnehme
dass ich den wurm aber anders und stellt
und vielleicht läuft es ja jetzt mal zu
diesen button darüber den ganzen meter
um sie zu holen
ich zeige es aber noch mal da drüben
[Musik]
gut dass es vielleicht ein bisschen zu
verlockend ja die ist ja nicht dumm
debatten ist jetzt gar nicht mehr in
ihrem sichtfeld hast du bei uns schon
vergessen wir sind debatten mal sonst du
denn dort
[Musik]
fein das geilste überhaupt und dann war
es an der zeit ihm mehrere wörter
beizubringen ich habe sport als
unterlage genommen dann alle knöpfe
drauf geklebt und auf einer skizze
geplant mit welchen werkzeugen wir
unsere waffen dort füllen werden ich
wollte zuerst gaben und nein braucht
machen das hatte ich aber ein bisschen
zu abstrakt und das zu verknüpfen also
haben wir uns dafür entschieden
streicheln
es reiche ja nicht reichen
also wenn man es gerade unser komplettes
mein sitz setzt nehmen jetzt gerade
unser komplettes board hier und zweimal
mit essen streicheln ist die meist das
ist wahrlich nicht bestreiten
[Musik]
streichen sie nachts nicht
streicheln meine streiche wie ihr seht
ja sehr viel angst vor allem was neues
bist du mein bis hinein
du bist und dann ist das erste mal
passiert was mit der mal was mit einmal
will essen super kombiniert wörter ja
wohin soll ich schauen bei sophie okay
ich schaue mal nach der sophie was mit
mir was ist mir mal was thomas hörst du
hast ja was ist denn mit mir meint wirst
angst wovor hast du angst ich habe
einfach gar nicht glauben können was ich
da eigentlich gerade gesehen habe wir
glauben nicht dass die angst vor sophie
hatte sondern dass sie ein
verunsichert war weil sie nicht
verstanden hatte was hier so viele
gerade macht was los über mein doc mai
findet ihr meines videos nicht nur auf
instagram sondern auch auf tik tok was
vielleicht mein nächstes experiment wird
mike ansprechen naja zumindest
kommunizieren nach nur sieben tagen hier
einfach mit unserem hund sprechen über
knöpfe oder hättest du es etwa geglaubt
bei kann natürlich nicht fehlen
das war das feld also nicht unbedingt
selbst wir das gemacht haben
jetzt müssen wir halt einen
konversationskurs patrick ist ja quasi
das zu überinterpretieren sie gibt
eigentlich nur voll wenig input aber das
was die konversation falls sie lebendig
macht ist ja dass du viel mehr
interpretiert ist was aber direkt auch
logisch ist als ich sagt thomas dann
drückt sie von thomas button dann sage
ich was du hast einmal die faule so
greife also als allererstes wenn ich
thomas ja ist okay also alles ist nicht
thomas tage muss sie auf thomas drauf
drücken
thomas thomas thomas thomas thomas
[Musik]
thomas may thomas thomas thomas schaaf
ein thomas ja wohin soll ich schauen mal
so sophie das kann mainz gut ausschalten
für so ein fake lernt wo man schon mal
ein paar erste gespräche hat und wirst
angst er ist schon krass also die dritte
random irgendwas ich kann das einfach
aus diesen ganzen zeug irgendwas
interpretieren ist es so einfach ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich an dieser stelle
überhaupt irgendein kann man dabei
bringen muss oder ob sie aber irgendwas
rändern drücken kann und ich nehme das
einfach 20 mal auf und irgendwann habe
ich schon irgendwas richtig cool ist das
wird interessant aber ich bringe jetzt
mal trotzdem was auf kommando bei als
nächstes soll sie quasi immer wenn ich
was los sage die taste drücken was los
sein lass los supercenter klopp sitzt
was mit normalen was mit einmal die mai
will essen ja klar
hahaha ich bekomme mittlerweile darauf
dass diese tecdax einfach nur zufällig
wir sind aber ich will trotzdem
probieren ihr das mal so als kommando
reinzubringen also micron thomas thomas
was los ich meine wir streichen in die
ecke wer ist jetzt da sein kann
dementsprechend also wir waren wie
gesagt haben wir einen sehr skeptisch
und wir wollten halt eigentlich nur
überprüfen wie leicht es ist sowas zu
faken und es ist eine brandneue hast du
eigentlich einfach nur die richtigen
buttons und egal welchen job sie drückt
man kann einfach jede geschichte sich
daraus zusammenreimen immer irgendwas
und selbst wenn nicht lässt nun sind
einfach zehn mal machen und irgendwann
die sind super trägt irgendwann 2
millionen wir haben nichts davon von dem
was sie gemacht hat eigentlich so
wirklich mit den echten wörtern
verknüpft was ich arbeite jetzt schon
denke ich dass man es theoretisch um
hund beibringen kann das ja auf
knopfdruck darum bittet nach draußen zu
dürfen oder ekel zu kriegen dass auf
jeden fall ich glaube das auch aber es
gibt einen einfachen punkt jetzt einfach
nicht gar nicht überschreiten kann
ich glaube mit holen jetzt aber nicht
sagen das muss nicht mehr lustig finden
wenn du sollst macht und wenn er mal auf
ihrem hintern vorbei schauen und hören
wir ein paar storage kosten minimal
andere fakes sätze sagt ja trotzdem
witzig sind
und ihr könnt jetzt auch hierauf tik tok
sprechen sehen und schauen ob das den
aufsteiger in deutschland vielleicht
hätte das nächste video hallo monate
passieren denn link zu meistern zu
können
marlies keck zurück und findet ihr
natürlich in einem schreiben und wenn
ihr mich auf diese weise begleitet
abonniert gerne im kanal
wir sehen uns im nächsten wieder ganz
gut
[Musik]